look at that there is a port this thing
is upgradable let's break some mac
studios just kidding i really hope we
don't break these but mkbhd said that
there is no way to take these apart to
clean out the fans so challenge accepted
personally i really want to see how
apple pulled off you know having so much
performance in such a small package and
getting it cool and with that the base
m1 max models they actually come in at
two pounds lighter which is a massive
difference because they have a different
cooling solution possibly in design and
definitely in materials now first
impressions guys this packaging is
amazing look at this cloth little strap
here the handle and this thing is so
dang heavy
man it is shocking it's pretty small but
the weight of it is just so dense with
parts we have this recycled kind of
cloth
material let's open this thing up
man i love how apple has this nice
presentation and packaging you're
spending a lot of money but they make
you feel better about it
all right look at this bad boy look at
all of those ports on the back side with
this huge exhaust and then at the bottom
we have the inlets and apple said that
they change the angle of the over 2 000
holes or so so the air like spins when
it comes in it is incredible and the
crazy thing is we actually bought three
of these mac studios and multiple
displays and other accessories spent
over 17 thousand dollars to provide the
very best mac studio and studio display
coverage on the internet so if you guys
want to see how they compare to each
other which upgrades are worth it the
thermals the wattages frequencies if
there's any throttling how much the ram
matters any of those questions and now
they compare to apple's other macs make
sure you guys hit that subscribe button
if you guys appreciate it and help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
with that said let's take this thing
apart now vadim and i spent a ton of
time yesterday trying to figure out the
best way to open this up because there
are no visible screws fasteners
anything to be able to lift it up so we
did notice online that seems like there
might be some screws underneath this
rubber but also some of these ports back
here go all the way through like this
power cord port it won't allow the
bottom just slip out along with these
usb type-cs so i think we're gonna have
to figure that out so the first thing
we're gonna do is take off this rubber
ring so for that we're gonna pull out
our ifixit kit not sponsored by fix it
but i fixed it please reach out to keep
repping your guys's awesome tools we'd
love to get sponsored with you let's go
ahead and grab a spudger here something
that's plastic so it won't damage it it
was hard to find a point to stick it in
but i got it here right at this edge and
i'm gonna just slowly try to get it to
go unglued and i just felt something
like a little dip in there possibly for
a screw at least that's what we're
hoping for this is definitely glued down
nicely or taped down yep all right all
right all right
wow okay now what is this what is that
it looks like braille hopefully it's not
like a secret magnetic key that you have
to put in there but we see the screws so
let's go ahead and find the right little
bit to fit guys if you guys do anything
techie at all you should buy one of
these kits we'll leave an affiliate link
down below they are super high quality
that one was too big so it looks like a
t3 bit all right wow apple got these
really really tight dang oh and now we
see it's actually starting to come apart
from its casing so it looks like it's
not impossible
to take this apart now as i am
unscrewing these i have to tell you guys
about our excellent new shirts that
vadim designed this is a nice subtle
designer if you guys see the details all
around this is the m1 ultra chip package
so it looks really cool here go ahead
and check out the link if you want to
see the full details and we will give
you 20 off for now if you use the coupon
code m1 ultra at checkout thank you guys
for supporting our efforts all right we
got the last screw here guys i am so
excited but we might have some more
challenges because of these thunderbolt
ports it looks like they are blocking it
from dropping but let's go ahead and see
all right
okay
well i guess there's more to unscrew
that was easier than i thought um wow so
i thought the whole shell would just
come off possibly maybe at an angle but
looks like this is a nice solid piece of
aluminum with these little pads
that's going to make sure there's no
vibration so very cool no flex like at
all there and here we have all right
this is what we were finding before
online these little blocks of aluminum
well there's actually three of them oh
yep they are antennas these things right
here you were right vadim it looks like
those are the antennas and the bottom of
this and this outside edge is actually
looks like plastic just like on the
iphones and ipads
to allow that signal to come through so
very cool now we also see the tiny
little speaker right over there um and
then that just fires what i guess down
through the little ports on the bottom
the air intakes so it looks like the
next step is to unconnect this whole top
portion which is the power supply
uh and then we're gonna have to release
this solid aluminum frame to get the
actual ports to pop out before we have
full access so this is built very well i
thought a lot of this would be plastic
but no it's all aluminum all right we
have those undone but it's not coming
off so we have another screw here
vadim
look at that
look at this there is a port this thing
is upgradable
okay um i don't know if i can here look
over here look from the angle i was
gonna unscrew that oh my goodness is
that what i think it is what is that so
obviously the ram is not upgradeable
it's on the soc that looks like you can
put an ssd into it and look you could
probably do that without even taking it
apart you pop it in turn it slide it in
and it's literally right from here just
screw that down and you can upgrade your
sse so it's not soldered on looks like
we might have another one on this side
right here look at that i'm guessing
it's the same thing
so if you didn't spring for a bunch of
uh ssd storage you didn't spend the
money later you should be able to plug
that in just like you can with their mac
pro that is awesome all right let's get
this power supply unconnected that's
probably how it gets powered to the
motherboard and bam it looks like it
does lift up now we have a couple cables
here all right here is one of them and
then this one here is the one that
actually connects to where your cable
plugs into the wall nice and easy to
remove it but be careful do not touch
any of this exposed stuff you can get
shocked man this is a lot more complex
than i expected the layering we have
antenna bands and cables going all
around the outside different shields and
looks like even the fan assembly is
mounted to the outer case this bottom
piece looks like it's just like a shield
to protect the motherboard from the
power supply and it's just suspended in
the air so i think the next thing i
gotta do is to unscrew this aluminum
frame to be able to access the ports and
unconnect those all right wow this whole
thing just lifts up so that's literally
for the bottom cover and the power
supply all aluminum no flex man this is
some high quality stuff look at that
dude
is that the m1 ultra chip right there
on the bottom of it look you got the
heat pipes wrapping around from there
you have this thing that holds it and
the screws here literally
just to lift it up so what is this on
the outside then some controllers or
could that be
like ram i thought the rams inside here
you know what let's just take the
stickers off this is angelica's mac
studio that she's going to be editing
our videos on so why not
let's pull this off alright so that
looks like it's some kind of power
controller right looks like the same
thing under this one and it looks like
something else under here i have no idea
there's more of these ships over here so
it looks like that doesn't matter
everything is underneath this uh heat
pipe and cooler which is actually nice
because with apple's new apple silicon
chips your ram is cooled down as well
not only the cpu and gpu chips you know
what this connector actually looks like
the same ones on my mac pro so let me go
grab that ssd and we'll see if it fits
alright guys so
yeah it's not gonna fit look at this
thing this thing is big and a lot slower
than the built-in one to the max studio
but let me see if the pins line up all
right looks like
let me see they look like they maybe
line up nope they're off a little bit
this section right here is shorter apple
said that the mac studio is not user
accessible just like they talked about
with the macbook pro most people thought
it means it's just soldered in but that
also gives us a clue that it could be
upgraded it's just not by the user
you're gonna have to take it into apple
just like you have to do with the imac
pro to get things like your ram upgraded
so that gives us lots of hope and of
course owc could come out and make
upgrade kits for just like they do for a
ton of mac stuff so that is going to be
awesome but next we're going to start
unscrewing some of these ports on the
sides man there are so many ribbon
cables here i really hope i don't mess
something up
looks like i have to take the ssd off to
access the usbc ports on the front and
this thing is literally taped on and
they don't want you to remove it but we
have to sorry angelica your mac studio
is getting a surgery done right now all
right
wow that was easy right there what if i
just want to put it into the other slot
so it's not in the way of those ports
you know i just plug the sucker in bam
tighten it down it'd be cool to see if
it actually would start up and not have
any issues it shouldn't
you know they designed these to be able
to add ssds
very cool the usbc port holder is done
and now let's remove this antenna
because we're going to need to access
the screw below it all right nice and
easy that's a massive antenna
let's lay this down yeah you're not
going to have a bluetooth problem no
bluetooth problems here apple made sure
of that let's finish off with these
antennas and then i'm going to try to
attempt to just remove these four
outside screws that hold down the fan
assembly and see if we just lift it up
without having to remove all of these
ports i'm really not looking forward to
putting this sucker back together before
we can start benchmarking man
so long ethernet port who got this bad
boy out all right let's try this again
can we clear it
nope we can't clear it so now i'm
getting rid of everything every single
thing including the speaker now has to
come off just to access more screws this
is insane it looks like we got a little
battery underneath there just to make
sure all your stuff is saved if you
power it off apple actually made a
little enclosure to make it sound better
instead of just having it be free air
which is appreciated apple cares all
right and we got our legacy ports out of
there and now for the culprit the one
thing that held everything together that
you have to remove everything for the
power jack now for the front usbc man
these are some rigid cables i've got to
say no windows manufacturer would ever
do this all these little screws and
cables why not just have the ports not
be as flush and just have one piece that
slides in well apple cares i guess make
it a really solid system and we also now
know that if at any time your little
usbc connector goes out or hdmi or
anything you can fix it yourself it's
not that difficult all right guys my
worst nightmare has come true
the last ports that i was trying to keep
in here without all these screws they're
all individuals have to come out you
literally have to disassemble everything
to get this out alright guys the second
moment of truth man if you guys
appreciate all of this and effort having
to put this back together afterwards
please buy a shirt
all right guys looks like he has to go
front forward first
which makes sense
oh man this is where all the weight is
oh
yeah
nice so it looks like the logo is not
used for antennas like they've done in
the past all of those are at the bottom
of the system so probably don't put it
on a metal desk or anything like that
and
here we have the computer
we got those dual fans
we have this section right here that
actually curves and seals towards the
back of the case in apple's renderings
they showed it having a gap which i
thought was weird
but it actually is longer super tight
fitting in there the fins here are super
super close together there's not a lot
of room there and it's crazy how front
heavy this is the back side barely wears
anything where we have these dual fans
the front is most of the weight
it's all copper yeah it's coated though
and it's also crazy how small this
motherboard is super thin this is the
whole computer here and the chip is
massive compared to other chips the cpu
and graphics we also just have only two
heat pipes coming up here to the cooler
as you guys could see
and they just connect right here they
don't spread out it's right here in the
center which is also interesting but i
guess we'll see how the thermals go when
we actually plug it in and test it out
all right guys we have to keep going
let's get this cooler off because i want
to see if we have dual cooling from this
side of the heat pipes and from the
other side we know apple is working on a
chip that has four chips connected
probably the m2 ultra or m2 ultra duo or
too extreme we don't know but let's see
if we have dual cooling so we're going
to start out by unscrewing
where our little heat pipes get
connected bam right there we know we
have thermal paste there interesting
that's not soldered on all right let's
flip it over now and get these fans
unscrewed and let's pop this thing off
wow okay that was easy look at that in
here that is a lot of space for air and
look at that
look at all these screws holding one
antenna cable
all the way
just so i can plug in on the other side
for this i'm so glad i didn't try to get
that removed i'm gonna leave that there
we have all these fins i saw those
screws i thought it might be holding it
to the motherboard but no so it's only
these top screws here probably these
four so it looks like it's still not
coming off
and this thing that holds down the m1
ultra chip
it also goes all the way through the
motherboard and it's connected to the
cooler on the other side which makes
sense
but dang i would not recommend doing
this and there is no way that i'm going
to
take apart another one i am just
dreading putting this back together all
right we got these off i can't believe
we took so much of this apart
what's crazy is that it looks like this
top plate
it is literally screwed
into the chip or into the motherboard
because that is held together oh wow
all
[Music]
there you right
the m oh
no this is crazy the m1 ultra is
literally cooled
to this whole thing
is this what is this heat pipes it
literally goes to this whole block and
this backside is literally cooling just
the back part of it to get it even
cooler i thought it was weird having
those two heat pipes and that is the
only way that it's transferring stuff
literally dual sided cooling
and look at that beauty right there it
is actually hidden well protected
yes i do see it i do see the apple logo
and we have
this whole thing look at this little
thermal material this whole casing
with that plate that goes straight to
the coolers that is incredible that's
insane that's copper
what's copper oh that bottom plate right
yeah i guess that is all copper yeah it
is for sure copper this is all copper
man look at that beauty look at that
guys or just like the shirt that you
should buy with promo code m1 ultra for
20 off you have this beautiful thing
with the apple logo
man that is incredible and we have
mission successful and look this m1
ultra is literally i don't know half of
the whole motherboard size
it is huge and it is thick
and it is incredible it's actually
really interesting how it just has
contact where the m1 ultra chip is
nowhere around so it really doesn't have
to cool down the memory it actually just
passively goes through but that little
shape right there shows exactly the size
of the m1 ultra so even though with
apple's animations with the m1 the m1
pro max and ultra looks huge that
literally is the size it is still nice
and small and it's nice that there's a
little extra space there for the thermal
compound once it squeezes out so there's
no issues with that said let's go ahead
and clean it off and see that apple logo
so there you guys go we have that apple
logo on there now you know just how big
the m1 ultra is both the package and
just the chipset we have this beautiful
look and just how crazy apple went
absolutely i don't know
insane building the system i do not envy
the people that are putting these
together day to day and just to show you
guys the difference here is a ryzen
processor the whole package compared to
apple's m1 ultra package that is crazy
but at the same time you see a size
difference apples has the ram in there
the controllers in there everything is
in there
up to 128 gigs of ram compared to just a
cpu so they have an incredible
incredible design guys thank you for
watching if you guys appreciate it
please subscribe we have so many
comparisons coming as far as the actual
workflows for real world stuff like
photo editing video editing coding uh
just so much stuff logic
you guys can check that out different
comparisons and also which upgrades are
worth it do you need the extra ram do
you need the 64 core ultra or should you
just get the 48 core like this one is
right here or is the m1 max good enough
what are the thermal differences all
that stuff that we are going to check
out as well as the display compared to
lg's compared to the pro display a lot
of detailed videos please wish me luck
putting this back together i'm going to
need it and check out one of these
shirts with the code m1 ultra we have a
couple great videos right over there for
you guys to watch while you wait click
above to subscribe this is max and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]